an event in 2013 put the world in chaos
when hackers told the car details of 40
million customers along with the
personal information of 70 million
customers like names addresses and phone
numbers from targets database the
hackers got their hands on this vast
amount of sensitive data by installing
malware on targets point of sale systems
this is just one example of thousands of
cyber crime activities occurring today
even the most prominent organizations
are only able to secure their systems
partially such as the situation of cyber
crimes today according to recent events
and future predictions cyber crimes
worldwide will cost organizations a
whopping 10.5 trillion dollars coming
from 3.5 trillion dollars in 2015 and
there's only one way to eliminate the
chances of these crimes that is by
implementing a solid wall of cyber
security and that can be done by hiring
more efficient cyber Security
Professionals that's why the demand for
cyber Security Professionals in the
cyber security industry is growing
rapidly with over 90 employment rate
if you also want to have a secure and
rapidly growing career in the future
then cyber security is the right option
for you but how to do that exactly well
hey everyone here I am with a new video
of Simply learn on the best cyber
security courses that will help you gain
perspective towards how you can build
your career in cyber security and what
courses will be best suited for you
before we begin the courses if you enjoy
watching these videos and find them
interesting please subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best videos
for you daily also hit the Bell icon to
get notified whenever we drop a new
video let's take a look at what's in the
video
we'll start this video by understanding
cyber security and then we'll see why
cyber security is the future following
that we'll take you through the salary
insights of a cyber security export and
will then take you through all the
courses offered by simply loan you can
choose from many courses as per your
needs and convenience each course
offered by simply learn has its perk and
is designed to bring the best out of the
learner so without any further Ado let's
start with what cyber security is cyber
security is the process of protecting
our devices networks and data from
unauthorized access tap and damage this
includes everything from your personal
email account to large corporations and
government agencies
there are many types of cyber threats
including viruses malware phishing
attacks and hacking attempts these
threats can lead to severe consequences
such as identity theft Financial loss
and even National Security threats so
how can we protect ourselves from these
threats the first step is to educate
ourselves on the different types of
threats out there we must know what to
look for and how to avoid falling victim
to cyber attacks this include things
like creating strong passwords being
wary of suspicious emails or messages
and regularly updating a software and
security settings
another critical aspect of cyber
security is using the right tools to
protect ourselves this include things
like antivirus software firewalls and
encryption these tools can help us
detect and prevent cyber threats before
they cause damage so let's move ahead
and we'll now see why cyber security is
the future
cyber security is the future because
cyber attacks are increasing everything
is connected and there's a growing need
for skilled professionals and the
importance of data protection is crucial
according to cyber security Ventures the
expected cost of cyber crimes will be
10.5 trillion US dollars
The Internet of Things is on the rise
everything is interconnected making it
vulnerable to cyber attacks the demand
for cyber Security Professionals is
increasing and it's estimated that there
will be 2.5 million unfilled cyber
security jobs by 2025. moving ahead
let's discuss the salary insights of
cyber security export according to Glass
2 the national average salary of a cyber
security specialist is 11 lakh 80 3000
in India with additional cash benefits
depending on the companies hiring you
the average salary of the same cyber
security specialist in the United States
can go up to 85 000 annually with
additional cash compensations other
cyber security jobs like ethical hackers
can earn up to 7 lakhs annually in India
while the same job designation in the
United States can get you around 88 000
annually
so let's see which courses are related
to cyber security and can bring the best
out of the learner the first course in
the list is the Cyber Security Experts
Masters program the cyber security
expert Masters program is a highly
sought after program that equips
individuals with the skills and
knowledge needed to excel in the fast
growing field of cyber security
this program comprises of four
comprehensive course designed to provide
individuals with the foundational and
advanced Knowledge and Skills in cyber
security the courses includes
introduction to cyber security this
course provides a foundational look at
today's cyber security landscape and
equips individuals with the tools to
evaluate and manage security protocols
in information processing system
com Tia Security Plus this certification
training is globally recognized and
covers network security and risk
management principles
ceh certified ethical hacker this course
trains individuals on the advanced
step-by-step methodologies that hackers
actually use such as writing virus codes
and reverse engineering
cissp training the certified Information
Systems security professional
certification is considered the gold
standard in information security
overall the cyber security expert
Masters program is an excellent
investment for individuals looking to
pursue a career in cyber security or
Advance their current career in this
fast growing field
the program provides individuals with
Comprehensive approaches and skills that
will help them become accomplished cyber
Security Professionals you can also get
a discount by using our coupon code ytb
E15 you can find the link for the same
in the description box as well you'll
get a free exam voucher for CE at
certification saving a lot of your money
and preparing you for the program along
with the exam voucher the second program
in the list is the postgraduate program
in cyber security
by enrolling in this postgraduate
program in cyber security you will gain
knowledge and expertise in safeguarding
your infrastructure and securing data
this postgraduate program in cyber
security will cover all the necessary
cyber security skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking IDs firewalls and honey
ports security and risk management
network security software development
security and many more not only that but
this program can also get you hired by
top companies like Microsoft IBM
Deloitte VMware Oracle and many other
Tech Giants
you'll also get to attend online
interactive master classes conducted by
the instructor from mitscc and gain
insights about advancements in cyber
security and understand the essential
skills needed to become an expert in
this rapidly growing domain the next
program in the list is the advanced
executive program in cyber security
you can enroll in the advanced executive
program in cyber security and enhance
your career prospects by becoming a
skilled industry professional in six
months
this program offers an immersive
learning experience emphasizing
practical applications making it ideal
for those seeking a more rewarding
career change
by joining the advanced executive
program in cyber security you'll acquire
Advanced knowledge in defensive cyber
security malware analysis application
security ethical hacking and more
offered in collaboration with triple it
Bangalore and npci this cyber security
program equips you with the
comprehensive expertise required to
identify potential opportunities and
innovation in cyber security sector the
global cyber security Market size stood
at 112 billion dollars in 2019 and is
projected to reach 345 billion dollars
by 2026. so now is the time to make a
career in the field of cyber security
and this Advanced executive program in
cyber security can help you back
whopping salary job companies like Ernst
and Young private limited Amazon
Microsoft Bosch Samsung IBM and Cisco
are actively looking for certified cyber
security export so what are you waiting
for enroll Now link is in the
description below the next program in
the list is the professional certificate
program in ethical hacking and
penetration testing
simply learns professional certificate
program in ethical hacking and
penetration testing is a comprehensive
course designed to help individuals gain
the skills and knowledge needed to
become an expert in vulnerability
assessment and penetration testing this
program is an excellent choice for
individuals looking to enter the cyber
security industry Security Professionals
Network administrators or anyone looking
to upgrade their cyber security skills
one of the key advantages of this
program is that you will learn more
about the concepts consequences
distinctions and limitations of ethical
hackings in this course the extensive
curriculum covers a wide range of topics
including the principle of ethical
hacking reconcines tools footprinting
techniques Network scanning IDF firewall
evasion techniques vulnerability risks
social engineering SQL injection web
server attack methodologies and more in
addition to the industry recognition the
program also offers participants access
to community of like-minded
professionals providing an opportunity
to network share ideas and learn from
each other
in conclusion simply learns professional
certificate program in ethical hacking
and penetration testing is an excellent
choice for individuals looking to enter
or Advance their career in ethical
hacking
with its comprehensive curriculum
industry recognition and community
support this program is sure to provide
participants with the skills and
knowledge needed to tackle the
challenges of the future the last course
in the list is the Caltech cyber
security boot camp according to
Glassdoor the average salary of a cyber
security specialist in the United States
is around hundred thousand dollars
so if this salary figure amazed you and
you also want to become one then you can
also kick start your career as a cyber
security professional through this
Caltech cyber security boot camp and
gain the skills and experience required
by organizations to protect their
critical systems and sensitive data from
cyber attacks through real world
projects in 26 weeks
by enrolling in this Caltech cyber
security boot camp you will gain
Proficiency in a range of areas related
to defensive and offensive cyber
security digital forensics penetration
testing infrastructure design and other
related subjects
the program curriculum labs and assisted
practices provide exposure to various
popular cyber security tools that are
currently in high demand the key
benefits of enrolling in this course
includes up to 26 containing educational
units and a Caltech ctme Circle
membership
simply learns Courier Service will also
help you get noticed by top hiring
companies like Netflix Amazon Microsoft
Google and many more on completion of
the cyber security bootcamp buy simply
learn and Caltech ctme you will gain a
completion certificate as well so for
admission to this boot camp in cyber
security candidates should have 18 years
of age and have a high school diploma
basic understanding of programming
Concepts and Mathematics can add more to
your skills if you don't have any job
experience don't worry there's no need
for the same so well that's a wrap on
our best cyber security courses for
beginners we hope you found this video
informative and helpful bye now you
should have a good understanding of the
different types of courses you can take
up to master the field of cyber security
if you are interested in learning more
about cyber security there are plenty of
resources available online you can also
check out our website for more
information on cyber security training
and certifications thank you for
watching and we'll see you next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you